conga real they're sustainable and
delicious but sadly no one wants to eat
them because they're so [ __ ] ugly
conger eels are monstrous creatures they
can grow up to ten foot long and can
weigh up to 250 pounds thousands of them
living the sea around Britain and it's a
waste not to eat them
I've come to Exmouth to meet Dave Curley
he's one of the few people I could find
who fishes for congas and he sells it in
his fish and chip Shack where's that
something with your haircut Oh makes me
go right oh good I joined you and this
thing's a huge honor I mean it can be
completely different to a freshwater eel
relating the same family but there I
mean they're humongous yeah yeah I've
seen hundreds back a hundred pounds I've
seen it yeah conned rails often live
inside wrecks so heading out to sea to
fish over one the fascinating thing
about conger eels
yeah they look [ __ ] ugly they are
ugly looking but you cut through that
flesh in its white gold is just as
lovely and it just hasn't quite got the
flavor it's caught but you're gonna
prove me wrong with that okay
we'll be catching the congas with rods
which is going to be a real challenge as
they're very difficult to fish so it's
gonna be a slow tuk-tuk-tuk toka then
bank bag yeah and when you know this on
it on when they're on the they're
ferocious Huntley
ah it's nonstop it is actually
physically very tiring to get one up in
the surface congas are tricky to catch
because they live within the wreck they
come out to take the bait and then knit
back into hiding something on ya
something on that damn [ __ ] Dom just
come off there damn I load up my hook
with more bait and try again they're
fighting yeah this is definitely Kong
grown here Gordon is it hot it's done
oh sure no one it coming off so [ __ ]
frequently it's frustrating but exciting
at the same time he's on Jesus Christ SS
strong Oh
fantastic [ __ ] what size is that house
casserole size I call it bloody how
that's not bad as it
not bad no love is so strong will show
absolutely right now yeah I think if you
just chop the straight across there
these buggers can really bite so the
quick is the most humane way to kill
them is to sever their spinal cord so
that's it Jesus Christ you got him you
got him bouillabaisse is one of my
favorite French fish dishes but I want
to create a British version using conga
to show Dave and his customers that this
eel can be even more delicious
so season at first okay and start the
process of a Congaree of bouillabaisse
yeah very similar to a classic French
bouillabaisse but no gray mullet no
monkfish no pause they lost like just
yes congas your Congo olive oil then add
a little black pepper salt and saffron
oil in skin side down into the pan now
this one when we start getting the
vegetables oh nice hot pan add some
olive oil
fennel carrots celery and star anis
crush a whole garlic add a handful of
schlotz and lastly cayenne pepper
apples little bit at the peak as ever
since I'm really help to see a little
stir for me please
so you tear down we got a color there
that's all we wanted on their fishing
but it smells amazing
lovely they've laid the pan with a
little bit of Pernod I sit down set
faster Shak burn off the alcohol and
mixing the vegetables yeah and the fish
evenly add a splash of wine fish stock
potatoes fresh tomatoes basil and
parsley to finish the dish cook it out
for 20 minutes and I'm gonna blend it
okay Swigert yes look at them all fish
and chips is off the menu yes
yeah please conger eel
we love conga it's so frustrating that
we do not eat enough Kong Grill so
please start buying me because in there
they clearly loved it it may be ugly but
it's [ __ ] delicious